die spd steckt in einer tiefen krise
nach dem wahl desaster bei der
europawahl und dem verlust der mehrheit
in bremen
fragt man sich in der partei wie soll es
weitergehen
weiter gehen kann es nur mit einer
inhaltlichen diskussion mit themen die
auch vor allen dingen junge menschen
erreichen aber stattdessen wird über
personal diskutiert wir haben bei uns
kevin kühnert den juso chef und ich muss
sie erstmal fragen bei dem was da jetzt
an desaster passiert ist wie viel würden
sich dann selber zu schreiben sie sind
mit thesen an die öffentlichkeit
gegangen sozialismus wagen würde ich das
mal so überschreiben
hat man ihnen im nachhinein nicht sagen
müssen du bist mit daran schuld dass wir
da gelandet sind wo wir gelandet sind
gibt ein paar wenige die das so sehen
scheint mir nicht die mehrheitsmeinung
zu sein und ich wehre mich grundsätzlich
schon länger dagegen dass wir beim blick
auf schlechte wahlergebnisse uns immer
die letzten wochen angucken es gibt so
ein volkssport in der spd aber auch in
anderen parteien immer so ein spiel zu
spielen wer ist schuld daran dass die
prozentpunkte 16 und 17 verloren
gegangen sind anstelle der frage wo sind
eigentlich die prozentpunkte 18 bis 30
oder 35 geblieben und wie kann man die
wieder zurückbekommen es ist doch
offensichtlich dass die spd auch eine
gewisse streitkultur in den letzten
jahren verlernt hat und insofern wäre
ich mich auch dagegen wenn gesagt wird
also vor der wahl kann man so eine
diskussion nicht anstoßen
es gibt keinen richtigen zeitpunkt dafür
über grundsätzliches in der gesellschaft
zu diskutieren und ich hätte ihnen jetzt
werde das vor gewusst hätten ein
papierstapel mitbringen können von
zuschriften die wir bekommen haben zu
diesem thema geht von hier bis und das
studio dach oder bis zur decke von vom
gebäude hier von leuten die gesagt haben
endlich wird diskutiert endlich geht es
um die großen fragen also ich bin
befangen aber ich schliesse mich der
these nicht an dass das jetzt nur der
große hinderungsgrund für diese
wahlkampagnen wir wollen noch mal über
diese
kapitalismuskritik würde ich sie mal
nennen später sprechen
zunächst einmal aber die frage ist nicht
tatsächlich die spd eine partei in der
viel zu sehr über personen und viel zu
wenig über themen geredet wird wir haben
ja jetzt nach diesen beiden
wahlergebnissen wider eine diskussion
darüber ist andrea nahles die richtige
da wird spekuliert dass martin schulz
sich engagieren will als fraktionschef
offenbar ist das auch noch nicht so ganz
vom tisch was erwarten sie denn wird es
eine große personal rochade geben
ganz aktuell wird ja jetzt in der
fraktion diskutiert und da muss ich
sagen ich bin kein teil der fraktionen
insofern ich habe da keine aktien im
spiel und ich muss das jetzt auch
einfach hinnehmen was die für sich
entscheiden wir sind ein zwei
beobachtungen dabei ganz wichtig der
eine punkt ist wir alle die
demokratischen parteien teile der medien
großer teil der politischen
öffentlichkeit sind in den letzten
jahren viel zu sehr dazu übergegangen
schnappatmung auf politische
entwicklungen zu reagieren das ist
natürlich leichter über den austausch
von köpfen zu sprechen als über
tiefgreifende ursachen dahinter über
politische entwicklungen darüber ob man
klimawandel oder digitalisierung
überhaupt politisch erfasst hat in
seiner dimension und wie man damit
umgeht und ich bin zunehmend gelang weit
von diesem umgang wir haben so ein
politisches gaffer thum immer nach war
das wie bei einem auto unfall alle
glotzen hinmachen ein handy handy video
davon zerreißen sich das mal darüber was
da passiert ist anstatt darüber zu reden
wie kann die unfallstelle entschärft
werden wie kann man verhindern dass so
etwas in zukunft noch mal vorkommen wie
kam es eigentlich dazu es ist ein sehr
wohl juristischer blick den wir im
moment auf politik haben und keine
partei sollte eigentlich besser als die
spd wissen dass mit irgendwelchen
schnell mal da hingehauchten
personalwechseln sich rein gar nichts
zum besseren wendet man merkt auch in
diesen tagen wieder
es wird über köpfe geredet aber damit
verbindet sich zumindest in meiner
wahrnehmung noch keine debatte darüber
welche themen müssen stärker in den
mittelpunkt welche strategie verfolgen
wir müssen wir uns nicht für andere
politische bündnisse öffnen um auch eine
wahlmöglichkeit zu haben und die auch an
wählerinnen und wähler weiterzugeben und
so lange das alles nicht passiert können
wir personal durchwechseln wir wollen es
wird keine folgen
auf der anderen seite ist personal das
womit sich bürger identifizieren oder
besser gesagt politik identifizieren und
das ist bei andrea nahles ganz offenbar
nicht gelohnt
das ist bei den grünen ganz anders das
sind jüngere menschen das sind im
zweifelsfall auch diejenigen die die
themen ansprechen aber die themen werden
dann auch personalisierte bei ihnen
warum geht das in der spd nicht in der
cdu geht es ja auch nicht so dolle weil
wir gewisse altlasten mit uns
herumschleppen sind dass ältere leute
oder themen nie das sind themen und
entwicklungen also wenn wenn zwei
parteien die union und die spd sei teile
der spd seit 20 jahren nahezu ohne
unterbrechung in der regierung sind im
falle der union jetzt seit 2005 komplett
ohne unterbrechung drin sind dann werden
köpfe nicht nur mit den aktuellen
inhalten sondern natürlich auch mit dem
was man erlebt hat in den letzten zehn
15 jahren assoziiert jeder der mal an
dem spd infostand gestanden hat weiß
ganz genau
man kriegt immer noch und ich bewerte
das gar nicht mehrwertsteuererhöhung
hartz4 agenda politik und so weiter um
die ohren gehauen und klar bei uns sind
auch immer noch leute unterwegs die
waren damals in verantwortung als das
passiert ist und natürlich schreiben
wählerinnen und wähler diesen leuten das
auch zu das ist auch ein teil von
personalisierung da haben die grünen
einfach glück die sind jetzt seit 14
jahren nicht mehr in der bundesregierung
vertreten deswegen lässt man robert
habeck auch durchgehend dass er in
manchen wesentlichen fragen im letzten
jahr die eine wie auch die andere
position eingenommen hat das ist im
moment alles irgendwie spannend und
interessant was dort passiert ich darf
den das auch gar nicht vor wir werden
mit unseren eigenen widersprüchen
konfrontiert und die bilden sich dann
manchmal auch in einzelnen personen und
deren politischen biografien aber muss
man nicht bei einer partei vorsitzenden
irgendwann mal die reißleine ziehen wenn
man sagt also das ist in der
öffentlichkeit so schlecht angekommen da
ist so wenig an eigenen themen umgesetzt
worden dass man doch mal überlegen muss
eine alternative auf zu machen also auch
eine alternative im sinne von jemand
jüngeren noch zunehmen der vielleicht
stärker verkörpert wir kümmern uns auch
um die jugend denn das wahlergebnis ist
ja nicht nur desaströse und vor allen
dingen auch die tatsache dass sie die
über 60-jährigen und im zweifelsfall die
cdu ja auch die über 60
jährigen erreichen aber nicht nur die
jungen leute es spricht auch gar nichts
dagegen auch mal über personal zu
diskutieren
aber sie haben eben gesagt wenn sich
damit eine andere orientierung verbindet
dann ist das interessant wenn
kandidaturen gegeneinander stehen wo ich
mich zwischen zwei konzepten von politik
entscheiden dann könnten sie doch einen
linken aus der spd nehmen wir zum
beispiel aus niedersachsen der
vertretene linke politik wäre das eine
ein kontrapunkt zu dem was wir im
augenblick erlebt aber in der
bundestagsfraktion zu 152 leute und ich
bin keiner davon und ich werde bin bin
kein teil dieser auseinandersetzung und
ich muss auch ehrlich sagen deswegen
ärgert mich auch dass das jetzt anhand
der fraktionen alles glatt ausdiskutiert
wird wir haben ein zielkonflikt in der
partei was wir eigentlich von einer
partei sein wollen wo unsere politischen
schwerpunkte sind ob wir das prinzip
auch lagen haben oder uns fokussieren
auf bestimmte themen deswegen müsste das
jetzt eigentlich auch in der partei
geklärt werden stattdessen wird eine
stellvertreter entscheidung in die
fraktion rhein gezogen wo nun mal eben
nur 152 von 450.000 spd-mitgliedern
sitzen und ich weigere mich von einem
kleinen kreis der auch nicht komplett
repräsentativ für die ganze partei
entscheiden zu lassen wo es mit den mit
unseren geschicken hingeht wir sind viel
zu sehr
berlin und funktionärs gesteuert als
partei das ist das ergibt sich so aus
dem politischen geschäft
aber wir tun gerade wenig dagegen um
unsere entscheidungsprozesse mal ein
bisschen zu öffnen wir sitzen in
vorstandssitzungen jeder erzählt was die
basis bei ihm zu hause so sagt es tut
natürlich auch manchmal ein bisschen
instrumentalisiert man kann für für und
gegen alles irgendeinen o-ton ins feld
führen aber diese leute fragen der
eigentlich nicht nicht selbst nicht auf
einem parteitag nicht bei einem
parteikonvent wir diskutieren noch nicht
darüber ob wir nicht den vorstand öffnen
sollten für leute die vielleicht nicht
im bundestag oder in
regierungsverantwortung sitzen ich
glaube das wären zeitgemäße diskussionen
das heißt aber eigentlich sagen sie die
struktur und möglicherweise trifft das
ja nicht nur auf die spd zu die struktur
einer partei um junge leute um neue
ideen zu entwickeln und dann auch in der
öffentlichkeit zu diskutieren einen
öffentlichen diskurs herzustellen
die funktioniert so nicht das stimmt die
struktur nicht mehr woran liegt denn das
ist das
tatsächlich daran oder muss man es damit
festmachen dass man sagt in der
hierarchie einer partei musst du eben
und das ist ein typisches typischer
reflex bei der spd aus dem ortsverband
kommen du musst ganz unten anfangen und
die vorarbeiten da ist man nun einfach
ein bisschen älter
na wenn das mal immer so wenigstens
funktionieren würde
ich glaube eher dass wir eine viel zu
ausgeprägte arbeitskreis und
arbeitsgruppen struktur haben es gibt
eine politische streitfragen und dann
wird irgendeine expertengremium
eingesetzt was ein kluges papier
schreiben soll
aber unsere öffentlichkeit funktioniert
heute nicht mehr darüber dass man ein
mehrseitiges papier veröffentlicht und
dann darauf setzt dass die frohe kunde
sich schon verbreiten wird die erfahrung
hat die union ja vor ein paar tagen
gemacht wenn man von menschen aus der
netzkultur angegriffen wird für seine
politischen positionen und sein
auftreten und man schickt als antwort
darauf ein 11 seitiges pdf zurück indem
man sich damit auseinander was haben sie
denn gemacht auf die retter auf das
ressort video den rivalen mit einem
video geantwortet und zwar mit unserem
generalsekretär lars klingbeil mit timo
werken im digital politiker aus dem
europaparlament und mit mir weil wir
einerseits zufällig an dem tag rat
zusammen unterwegs waren weil wir
gedacht haben na ja die sind jüngere
leute in der spd wir sind auch in der
netzwelt selber unterwegs wir sind auch
so groß geworden
wir können hier eine authentische
antwort geben wir haben darauf
verzichtet und welche freigabe schreite
schleifen durch die partei zu machen und
zu fragen ist das in ordnung stimmt der
text da drin sondern wir haben das
einfach mal ohne skript oder so drauflos
gesprochen was wir dazu denken wo wir
widersprechen wo wir zustimmen wo wir
eigene defizite sehen und das ist auch
ein gut gepflegtes wie du gewesen für
das wir auch viel zustimmung bekommen
haben im sinne von deshalb will ich euch
jetzt vielleicht noch nicht das war auch
gar nicht das ansinnen dabei aber hey
schön dass da jemand uns ernst nimmt und
uns auf unserer ebene mich dort wo wir
uns im alltag bewegen im netz
tatsächlich auch geantwortet hat das ist
ein baustein von ganz vielen wie man
diese leute tatsächlich auch wieder
rankommen kann
jetzt haben sie von kommunikation
gesprochen reden wir mal über die themen
wir haben das eben schon mal
angesprochen dass müssen themen sein die
nicht nur
einfach mal kontrapunktisch gesetzt
werden da hatte man bei ihnen so ein
bisschen den eindruck die dialektik ist
bei ihnen natürlich ganz tief verankert
sie sagen einfach mal mit diesem
kapitalismus geht es so nicht weiter
dann redet man über das gegenstück den
sozialismus und dann findet man in 242
nach der dialektischen theorie eine
synthese
nun haben sie aber von vielen punkten
gesprochen der enteignung der
verstaatlichung dann müssen
immobilienkonzerne enteignet wenn das
hat ja unglaublich viele verschreckt
auch wenn sie sagen sie haben
bündelweise positive reaktionen die
anderen bündel weisen reaktionen waren
ja negativ und die sind ja auch bei der
spd so negativ bei der wahl ausgegangen
die politische auseinandersetzung
besteht darin dass es unterschiedliche
meinungen gibt also wenn ein vorschlag
deshalb falsch ist weil leute ihm
widersprechen
dann haben wir echt ein problem in
unserer demokratischen
auseinandersetzung ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass man ein paar mehr leute
in der sache reagieren es gab ein paar
fdp-abgeordnete die haben zum beispiel
interessanten artikel geschrieben in dem
sie sich wirklich mal sachlich mit den
mit den vorschlägen auseinandergesetzt
haben ein großteil der anderen leute
sind aber nur ddr venezuela und
nordkorea vergleiche eingefallen was
nicht nur abstrus ist sondern auch eine
völlig wurst igge verweigerung jeder
politischen debatte bedeutet ich erwarte
nicht dass man mir zustimmt man kann das
alles ganz fürchterlich finden was ich
gesagt habe ich erwarte dass wir in der
lage sind zwischen demokratischen
parteien uns mit vorschlägen
auseinanderzusetzen und ich habe auch
kein fantasieland gezeichnet sondern ich
habe im kern nicht mal verstärkungen
gefordert aber ich bin eingegangen auf
dinge die unser grundgesetz in artikel
14 und 15 bereit hält nämlich die ganz
klare aussage
das ist wenn wir das demokratisch
entscheiden momente geben kann in denen
das gemeinwohlinteresse das interesse
der mehrheit wichtiger sein kann als das
interesse des einzelnen zum beispiel
nach profit was er mit seinem
unternehmen gerne erreichen möchte das
ist geübte praxis andreas scheuer
verkehrsminister und nicht aus meiner
partei sondern von der csu ist laut
einer aktuellen kleinen anfrage im
bundestag gerade dabei oder war zuletzt
dabei bei mehr als 200 projekten im
ländlichen raum land gegen entschädigung
zu nehmen damit dort straßen und
autobahnen
gebaut werden können der juso chef
sinniert darüber der csu
verkehrsminister macht ist also da sehen
sie die die schiefe ebene in unserer
politischen debatte dass wir uns da
unnötige denkverbote auf allen java ist
das so zum beispiel wenn sie es wenn es
um den begriff des eigentums geht der
ist ja vor allen dingen im zusammenhang
mit der immobilien situation in
deutschland von ihnen in frage gestellt
worden
wenn sie an diesem begriff herangehen
müssen sie doch erwarten dass bürger
sagen ich lasse mir doch nichts
wegnehmen von dem was ich über viele
jahrzehnte erarbeitet habe
da ist doch eine reaktion die sie vorher
schon einschätzen können warum sind sie
mit einer so massiven forderungen
überhaupt gar nicht gefordert
irgendjemand sein eigentum wegzunehmen
das ist schlicht und ergreifend nicht
der inhalt dieses interviews gewesen ich
habe darauf hingewiesen und das ist nun
mal eine tatsache dass wir in großen und
mittlerweile auch in kleinen städten
eine explodierende mieten situation
haben ich muss mir nur die steigerung
der mieten gegen die entwicklung der
löhne halten und dann sehe ich dass wir
dort auf eine soziale katastrophe zu
laufen weil das eine mit dem anderen
ganz offenkundig nicht mehr schritt
halten kann so und mieten steigen nun
mal nicht weil irgendein gesetz
verordnet hat das mieten steigen sondern
weil leute damit profit machen weil wir
große wohn konzerne haben die auf kosten
der mieterinnen und mieter investitionen
in die gebäudesubstanz in die sauberkeit
in die sicherheit einsparen damit sie
rendite an ihre anteilseigner auszahlen
können sie erhöhen die mieten vorgeblich
um damit irgendwas im wohnumfeld zu
verbessern
was aber für viele leute sich einfach
nicht einstellt ich mache selber
kommunalpolitik in meinem berliner
bezirk ich sehe auch die ganzen leute
die bei uns aufschlagen und sagen wir
wohnen in genau solchen immobilien von
diesen großen konzern und wir werden wie
der letzte dreck von den behandelt ja
natürlich können wir jetzt eine
philosophische diskussion über
eigentumsfragen führen es im prinzip
unnötig weil das grundgesetz gibt alle
antworten darauf aber ich muss doch als
politik eine erkenntnis daraus ziehen
wenn ich sehe dass reihenweise menschen
aus ihrem wohnumfeld vertrieben werden
von groß- eltern vielleicht weg die mal
auf die kinder aufpassen von kita und
schule wo man sich also im sozialen
umfeld eingerichtet hat das ist doch ein
sozialer sprengstoff der da ist und wo
offensichtlich die alte maxime der markt
wird schon regeln es eben nicht regelt
weil genau
dieser markt dem der großteil unserer
wohnung in deutschland gehört nicht dazu
in der lage ist sozial verträglich das
grundbedürfnis nach einem dach über dem
kopf zu befriedigen so dass man nur eine
feststellung dann müssen sie doch als
berliner wütend sein wenn sie
mitbekommen haben dass es eine
diskussion vor vielen jahren gab was ist
in tempelhof lose sind ja selber
kommunalpolitischen tempelhof engagiert
da ist ein ganz großer flughafen mit
einer großen tradition zugemacht worden
und da gibt es freie flächen ohne ende
mitten in berlin selber und da wird
nicht gebaut weil man irgendwann mal
gesagt hat wir fragen die bürger und die
bürger umgesetzt
dann möchte man lieber grillen und da
möchten wir lieber irgendwie
schlittschuhlaufen im winter und im
sommer mit rollerblades laufen das ist
doch grotesk ist da nicht auch der
bürger irgendwie in einer falschen
orientierung
die geschichte fängt eigentlich einen
schritt weiter vorne an also sie haben
recht aber nicht wir haben die leute
gefragt sondern das ermöglicht die
volksgesetzgebung in berlin haben selber
gesagt wir wollen entscheidend zu dieser
frage es ist ihr gutes recht und leider
ist es nicht in unserem sinne
ausgegangen spd hat sich für eine
behutsame bebauung am rand eingesetzt
über die ursache fängt ja vorher an wir
haben auch in berlin auch unter nach rot
roten regierung wohnungsbestände
verkauft anfang der 2000er jahre und
diese feststellung ist deshalb wichtig
weil man sieht die entwicklung auf dem
wohnungsmarkt übrigens genauso wie in
der pflege oder beim öffentlichen
nahverkehr sind nur symptome einer
größeren entwicklung deshalb diese
kapitalismus diskussion die eigentliche
ursache ist dass wir uns irgendwann mal
haben einreden lassen eine ideologie die
uns gesagt hat nur ein schlanker staat
ist ein guter start
ein guter haushalt es einer der
ausgeglichen ist ja keine schulden macht
wo am ende des jahres eine schwarze null
steht
aber was ist der preis den wir dafür
bezahlt haben wir haben unser
tafelsilber verhökert ob es die
öffentlichen wohnung waren ob es
freiflächen in der stadt waren die wir
ein private zur bebauung verkauft haben
die wir heute dringend bräuchten um dort
bezahlbares wohnen zu schaffen
wir haben pflege zum teil privatisiert
die hälfte der pflege heimplätze in
deutschland das unter dem dach von
pflege konzern auch die stoßen rendite
aus da muss man sich nicht wundern warum
die situation in den heimen ist wie sie
ist wir haben post und anderes zum teil
privatisiert heute wundern wir uns
darüber
warum paketboten in ihren in ihren autos
nachts schlafen müssen weil sie um ihren
mindestlohn sogar noch betrogen werden
also all das sind entwicklungen die aus
einer ideologie heraus kommen nämlich
der ideologie dass der markt auch die
sensibelsten bereiche unseres
zusammenlebens am besten und zwar besser
als der staat regeln kann und jedes
einzelne dieser beispiele wohnen
mobilität die im ländlichen raum
zunehmend eingeschränkt wird der umgang
auch mit unserer natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen mit der umwelt und wie
wir sie versiegeln und mit monokulturen
zu pflanzen und so weiter all das sind
die sichtbaren ergebnisse dieser politik
und sie zeigen eben dass der markt dort
versagt hat dann brauchen wir aber noch
kein sozialismus sondern brauchen wir
einen angepasst und kapitalismus wenn
sie davon ausgehen dass diese bereiche
stärker vom kart vom staat kontrolliert
werden müssten wo der staat stärker
eingreifen müsste wo man vielleicht in
der vergangenheit in ihrer nach ihrer
idee zu viel freiheit den privaten
gegeben hat dann müsste man doch in
manchen nur im grunde ein schritt zurück
gehen und sagen hier setzen wir wieder
stärkere staatliche kontrolle ein
und dann haben wir eine situation die
sie akzeptieren können da muss man ja
keine völlig neue gesellschaftliche
utopie entwickeln die ja nun oft genug
danebengegangen ist in westberlin groß
geworden
ich glaube wenn sie nach in den osten
berlins gehen da werden sie böse böse
reaktionen erfahren weil die sagen das
haben wir doch ausprobiert das ist doch
schief gegangen wenn wir aber nochmal
auf die groko zurückgehen die sie
abgelehnt haben als sie sich bildete
wenn wir eine konstellation jetzt sehen
bei dem großen thema klimaschutz wo
viele junge leute auf die straße gehen
dann freitags computer was auch offenbar
dazu beigetragen hat dass die grünen so
stark gewählt worden
dann sehen wir in der groko eine
umweltministerin von der spd schulze und
einen cdu-minister altmaier der genau
das bremst was sie an klimaschutz
modellen haben will
kann so eine groko funktionieren lassen
sie mich ein satz bitte noch zu
ostberlin sage an der stelle weil das
natürlich schon diese ddr andeutung sind
ja immer wieder auch gekommen
die leute die in der ddr gelebt haben
haben vor allem in einem
undemokratischen staat gelebt einem
staat der mauern aufgestellt hat der auf
leute geschossen hat die dieses land
verlassen wollten in dem freie
meinungsäußerung nur bedingt möglich war
in dem es keine freien wahlen gab und so
weiter also die grundbestandteile eines
demokratischen zusammenlebens waren
nicht erfüllt bevor wir aber irgendeiner
frage von der art des wirtschaftens in
diesem staat überhaupt erstmal
angekommen sind zu keiner dieser
komponenten der ddr habe ich mich in
irgendeiner weise befürwortet geäußert
ich bin der allerletzte der dazu wie ich
will keine planwirtschaft ich will keine
diktatur von irgendeiner partei oder
irgend einer kaste von alten männern die
meinen die weisheit mit löffeln
gefressen zu haben
mir geht es darum dass gesellschaftliche
veränderungen demokratisch herbeigeführt
werden und gerade im osten sieht man an
vielen stellen die auswirkungen von
einer politik die nur auf den markt
gesetzt hat gerade dort sind viele im
ländlichen raum abgehängt von den
vorzügen einer eigentlich sehr reichen
gesellschaft gerade dort hat die
treuhand damals dafür gesorgt dass ganze
biografien zerstört worden sind
deshalb glaube ich diese debatte dort
sehr anschlussfähig ist es hat eben
genau nichts mit ddr zu tun nichts liegt
mir ferner nicht zuletzt als mitglied
einer partei die erst zwangs fusioniert
und am ende faktisch verboten wurde im
osten unsere leute haben im knast
gesessen
dafür dass sie ihre meinung dort sagen
wollten also das ist wirklich ganz weit
von meiner position weg das wird was wir
beim thema klima im moment erleben das
reiht sich eigentlich in die eben
genannten beispiele mit ein was wir bei
klima sehen ist dass die klassischen
mechanismen wie man mit einem
politischen thema umgeht man verhandelt
darüber man versucht einen mittelweg zu
finden man schiebt vielleicht was auf
oder sagt das machen wir diese
legislatur und den anderen teil der
nächste das entzieht sich der logik des
themas klima denn der klimawandel ist
fakt und wir haben nur noch einen
begrenzten zeitraum bis zum beispiel die
erderwärmung soweit angestiegen ist dass
schäden entstehen die nicht mehr
reparierbar sind auch nicht mit
milliarden und abermilliarden
investitionen
irgendwann in 20 jahren das heißt nicht
nur die große koalition sondern jede
koalition kommt bei diesem thema an die
grenzen dessen was man in einem
koalitionsausschuss miteinander
ausbaldowern kann weil die kraft des
faktischen dessen was draußen passiert
der dürre und der hitzesommer die wir
erleben der menschen die sich in
millionenzahl auf die flucht begeben
weil ihre natürlichen lebensgrundlagen
in den sub sahara region oder anderswo
nicht mehr gewährleistet sind das sind
fakten an denen wir einfach nicht vorbei
kommen natürlich kann man dazu jetzt
noch 23 verhandlungsrunden mit den
industrieverbänden machen und so weiter
aber es wird alles nichts daran ändern
dass man mit dem klima nicht verhandeln
kann sondern sich nur mit dessen
auswirkungen noch beschäftigen
dann können die beiden noch gar nicht
verhandeln wie kann denn eine an
umweltministerin von der spd mit herrn
alten maya der sie bremst verhandeln
dann müssen sie doch sagen an einem
gewissen punkt wenn das ein so
existenzielles problem es müssen wir
sagen jetzt ist schluss jetzt geht das
nicht genau dafür haben wir ja im
koalitionsvertrag aufgeschrieben in dem
auch ein klares datum drin steht die
union hat ihre unterschrift unter einen
koalitionsvertrag gesetz in dem steht
2009/10 dieses jahr was noch sieben
monate lang ist werden wir ein
klimaschutzgesetz beschließen und die
umweltministerin svenja schulze hat von
vornherein klar gemacht ihre
vorstellungen und damit auch die der spd
von einem klimaschutzgesetz ist nicht
eine ansammlung von warmen worten indem
wir zum hundertsten mal betonen dass wir
die pariser klimaschutzziele einhalten
wollen der worte sind genug ausgetauscht
werden es 100 mal dazu bekannt dass
alles nicht der punkt sie will und wir
wollen dass alle in der spd dass das
klimaschutzgesetz die gebrauchsanweisung
wird die uns den weg durch die nächsten
jahre und jahrzehnte weist welcher
sektor soll wie viel einsparen also wie
sehen die gebäude der zukunft aus in
ihrer energiebilanz wie produziert die
industrie in zukunft wann wollen wir co2
emissionen neutral sein wie schnell
kriegen wir es hin dass die
landwirtschaft die verbesserung unserer
böden mit pestiziden abbaut ganz klar
und überprüfbar und zwar nicht in 15
jahres abständen über das sonst immer
gemacht haben sondern in kleinen
schritten damit wählerinnen und wähler
von der nächsten wahl nämlich auch
überprüfen können haben die es ernst
gemeint sind die ihren selbstgesteckten
zielen nachgekommen oder muss ich die
abwählen weil die auf der bremse stehen
wenn es
unsere natürlichen lebens gehabt gehen
sie dann aus der koalition nicht sie
persönlich geht die spd dann raus können
sie sich vorstellen dass die spitze der
partei sagt dann noch immer nicht mehr
mit und beziehen die minister zurück sie
sprechen den entscheidenden punkt an ich
alleine entscheide es nicht aber ich
habe koalitionsverträge immer so
verstanden dass man die nicht zum spaß
auf schreibt ich war unterlegen mit den
jusos letztes jahr bei der debatte um
die große koalition wir haben verloren
wir uns nicht durchgesetzt also ist die
partei in diese koalition reingegangen
dann erwarte ich aber auch dass der
vertrag den wir unterschrieben haben
ohne wenn und aber die
geschäftsgrundlage ist und wenn da
drinsteht 2009/10 rechtswirksam das ist
der wortlaut ein klimaschutzgesetz dann
muss ich die koalition dort an ihren
eigenen worten messen und ich hab nicht
ohne grund jetzt nach dieser wahl
schlappe am sonntag mit ralf stegner und
dem matthias miersch aus der
bundestagsfraktion unserem
profiliertesten umweltpolitiker zusammen
ein papier geschrieben indem wir alle
drei zusammen und die anderen beiden
waren wenn auch unter schmerzen
befürworter dieser großen koalition wo
wir uns gemeinsam dazu bekannt haben für
uns ist dieses klimaschutzgesetz einer
von mehreren deal breaker wenn es darum
geht ob wir weiter koalieren oder nicht
für uns steigt oder fällt die
möglichkeit einer weiteren
zusammenarbeit mit diesem thema weil wir
nicht bereit sind zukunft für die
nächsten generationen weiter aufs spiel
wenn sie da eine mehrheit bekämen in der
partei beziehungsweise der parteispitze
können wir uns dann vorstellen dass
jemand wie andrea nahles sagt das ist
zwar alles ganz prima mit der grund
rannte aber so radikal will ich da auch
nicht vorgehen und doch hin schmeißt mit
der koalition meinen sie jetzt das ist
jetzt ein diskussionsprozess wir sitzen
nächsten montag wieder im parteivorstand
zusammen weil wir mit unserer debatte
noch lange nicht fertig sind das ist
auch normal nach so einem wahlergebnis
und nochmal wir haben von seiten der
parteilinken unsere kriterien jetzt klar
benannt und die haben wir uns eben nicht
ausgedacht sondern wir messen da sind
wir ganz ähnlich wie freiheit ist future
wir messen die regierung an dem was sie
sich selbst vorgenommen hat weder frau
das verfüttern noch wir sind irgendwie
eine revolutionäre bewegung im moment
die von den regierenden etwas einfordert
was die gar nicht leisten können sondern
wir bestehen darauf dass ziele die wir
uns gesetzt haben nicht nur als es
de sondern die ganze bundesregierung mit
der selbst ernannte klimakanzlerin
angela merkel und allen die dazu gehören
dass diese ziele jetzt konkret mit
maßnahmen unterfüttert werden und jeder
der dort im weg steht ist dann in seiner
aufgabe falsch aufgehoben werden wenn
der landwirtschaftsministerin haben die
bei dem ersten konflikt der sich
vielleicht auch im bereich der
landwirtschaft ergibt sofort sagt ich
gehe jetzt an die spitze der
demonstration des bauernverbandes ohne
auch nur eine sekunde darüber
nachgedacht zu haben was eigentlich ihr
beitrag aus dem amt sein kann um dort
ein spar ziele auch erreichen zu können
der ist falsch ein der ist falsch
abgebogen weil wir haben schon zu viel
zeit verplempert wir werden zum
jahreswechsel 2020 die ziele die wir uns
bis dahin gesetzt haben verfehlen wir
haben uns im bereich verkehr bauen
landwirtschaft hatten wir uns
vorgenommen seit 2005 bis jetzt zum
nächsten jahreswechsel gesehen
20 prozent emissionen einzusparen wir
stehen bei drei prozent einsparungen im
moment und das ist nicht nur eine
politische misslungen die dort passiert
ist und ärgerlich sondern es kostet ab
nächstem jahr auch richtig geld weil wir
uns verpflichtet haben wenn wir die
selbst gesteckten ziele nicht erreichten
dafür zu blechen und es geht dann wieder
auf kosten egal wenn sie dieses papier
geschrieben haben und wenn sie sozusagen
die linken in der partei hinter sich
haben wie viele sind denn das ist das
eine mehrheit im zweifelsfall in der spd
oder wird das zwar als papier
wahrgenommen und welche ja das ein oder
andere ist ja richtig aber letztendlich
ende des jahres wird es doch nicht als
mehrheit der spd mitgetragen und sie
stehen wieder da und sagen wir haben
zwar gute ziele vorgegeben aber die
werden in der partei nicht erreicht wie
die kräfteverhältnisse waren das haben
wir letztes jahr gesehen wir hatten ein
bisschen mehr als ein drittel der
stimmen bei unseren mitgliedern gegen
die große koalition jetzt möchte ich
nicht mutmaßen darüber wie sich die
stimmung entwickelt hat aber ich habe ja
nicht ohne grund darauf hingewiesen dass
meine beiden ko autoren sozusagen mir
schon stehen zwei von denjenigen waren
die letztes jahr noch gesagt haben okay
wir sehen die alternative nicht wir
machen diese koalition ich glaube sie
stehen in ihrem erkenntnisprozess
stellvertretend für eine ganze reihe von
spd-mitgliedern die sagen wir haben es
jetzt zunächst einmal versucht wir sehen
wir kommen nicht voran und damit meine
ich nicht nur die umfragewerte der spd
die müssen sich auch
nachrangig einordnen hinter themen wie
dem klimaschutz sondern wir kommen in
der sache bei solchen themen nicht voran
manches haben wir geschafft in der
koalition ist keine frage aber bei einer
der existenz oder der existenziellen
frage der nächsten jahre kommen wir
stand jetzt nicht voran und insofern ist
das glaube ich repräsentativ für viele
wir werden klären müssen in den nächsten
tage in der spd was diese halbzeitbilanz
die wir uns verordnet haben dass wir
nach der hälfte der zeit gucken machen
wir weiter oder machen wir nicht was das
eigentlich bedeutet meine klare
erwartung ist dass ein parteitag darüber
entscheiden muss das ist nach unserem
staat unser höchstes gremium in der
partei alles andere halte ich für
legitim wenn eine kleinere runde darüber
entscheiden soll ob wir weitermachen
oder nicht
und insofern muss dass spätestens ende
des jahres passieren passenderweise dann
wenn laut koalitionsvertrag das
klimaschutzgesetz ja auch beschlossen
dass ein passender weise dann wenn drei
wahlen noch einmal im osten von
deutschland durchgeführt worden sind
haben sie den daumen runter oder hoch
für den herbst für die weitere arbeiter
kroko ich bin immer dafür sich an
spielregeln die man sich zusammen
gegeben hat zu halten mir fällt das
schwer sage ich ihnen ehrlich weil ich
wollte nicht in diese koalition rein
aber ich habe erwartet wenn wir uns
durchgesetzt hätten mit unserer position
dass die unterlegene seite sich dann
auch daran hält und daher gehört es auch
zur demokratie dazu dass ich mich jetzt
auch daran halte und diese zwei jahre
oder diese halbzeitbilanz auch mit
abwarten ich gebe meine meinung gerne
dazu was dort passiert ich unterstütze
auch dort wo ich kann weil solange diese
regierung noch arbeitet ist das nun mal
das womit wir arbeiten müssen
ich versuche nicht künstlich sand ins
getriebe zu streuen wenn wir zum
beispiel projekte jesus wenn wir über
die reform des berufsbildungsgesetzes
reden und dass wir jetzt ein mindestlohn
für auszubildende einführen dafür haben
wir jahrelang gekämpft ich wäre ja schön
bescheuert wenn ich 100 50.000 junge
machen das jetzt verwehren würde nur
damit sich meine selbst erfüllende
prophezeiung einstellt dass die große
koalition uns nicht voranbringt aber am
ende messe ich die regierenden daran was
sie sich selber vorgenommen haben und
sie haben es ja beschrieben im moment
haben wir beim thema klima
auseinandersetzung zwischen der
umweltministerin von uns
die klare verbindliche maßnahmen die
auch überprüfbar sind einfordert und
nach blockierenden union
und wenn das am ende des jahres immer
noch die konfliktlage ist dann glaube
ich brauchen wir auch überhaupt keine
sorge davor haben dann gegebenenfalls zu
sagen guten tag und guten weg weil wir
erstens zu unserer haltung gestanden
haben und uns sehen lassen können vor
leuten damit und man auch mit einer
klaren kontroverse in den nächst
wahlauseinandersetzung reingehen kann
und zwar mit einer kontroverse um das
thema unserer zeit bei dem es eben nicht
nur um die grünen gegen alle anderen
geht sondern wenn man sich die
tagespolitik anguckt auch um union gegen
spd gehört dank für das gespräch